if we're talking about how do I start a
successful YouTube channel from scratch
one of the most underrated things is
getting your Niche right getting a your
topic right and don't let that be
confused with starting messy and don't
let that be confused nobody wants to
hear this but let's say you started a
YouTube channel wrong I think that's
still okay it never really worked you
did 50 to 100 videos one of the most
painful things could be pivoting your
Niche or starting a second Channel but
people make the mistake that a lot of
times that's what it takes to find
success there's a stat that says the
average successful entrepreneur that
like gets through the the dip of hard
work and getting cash flow and getting
startup happening and actually makes it
to some level of success and
sustainability has started 2.6
businesses so what does that mean they
have one successful business and out of
one to two that failed so one like on
average so any successful entrepreneur
business owner that now has a successful
business on average had at least one
fail or two fail before they found the
one that worked I think that could be
similar to YouTube as well and it may
not be that you actually have to have a
different Channel but I think that
should give you permission to like what
if my first videos suck they will your
first videos will be your worst videos
you know it' be terrible but though you
know your way to get to success I heard
one person put it this way the recipe to
get to success is suck suck
suckcess your first three or 30 videos
might suck they might not be very good
but that's what leads to success so
start before you're ready then dial in
that Clarity I think it's key what
you're saying about the ability to Pivot
that one out of those three businesses
ideas is the one that takes off but
there's two failed ones in there because
so many people ask us like well I I have
this channel already and like I don't
know what to do with it so we're saying
then don't do that channel like if if
follow all of the advice listen to Sean
kenel and other experts and actually you
know don't be afraid to Pivot and to
change into um you know after you're
taking in all of this advice and so I
think that one is really key for a lot
of people listening because a lot of
people are going to need to Pivot after
listening to a lot of this training if
you're going to start a channel it's not
enough to just start it because
technically to start a channel right you
just got to set it up but what what we
mean is like can we start a channel that
has some level of consistency on it and
I would
recommend um you know there's so many
different answers to this question
question but it's like how many videos
should I upload a week I would recommend
one video a week and I would want to
Define that one thoughtful strategic
quality
researched crafted video per week I
don't mean it has to be edited or
anything again you may be able to just
hit record talk for seven minutes turn
the camera off and upload it but for
that seven minutes to be as powerful as
possible having a little practice having
a little planning um having some notes
in front of you thinking about what the
title is ahead of time thinking through
it prior planning prevents poor
performance and one of the biggest
opportunities if you want to succeed on
YouTube is consolidating time and saving
people time here's what I mean there's a
really successful personal finance
YouTuber named Graham stefen and one of
the things he's known for is he puts out
great research videos that are concise
clear and they really take complex
information and they make it simple well
what does he do he's known for
researching 20 30 40 hours for one video
now I'm not saying you have to take that
much time to be successful but think
about what happens if he if he
researches and plans for 20 hours and
the final product of his video is 10
minutes it's one of the reasons why the
video is so successful because we're all
so busy in our lives you're doing the
heavy lifting again even if you don't
edit if you take an hour or two hours or
three hours to prepare and then all of
that time preparing you've Consolidated
it down into a 3 to 5 minute or a
13-minute video you're doing a service
to people that's why people feel the
value of it the the flip side is true if
you just wing it it kind of reminds me
of my first video I was like listen this
my first video um I'm not going to be
energetic or entertaining I don't even
have a plan and that video didn't go
viral like CU there was no plan there
was no energy I didn't really go into it
intentionally so one long form upload
per week to clarify I think that there's
it gets interesting with YouTube shorts
those are much easier to create it's
fine to start with YouTube shorts
there's going to be vertical video 60
seconds or less that maybe switches it
up so if you can do a long form video
and a couple shorts totally fine if you
have bandwidth for more great but I
think people are
underestimating committing to uploading
just one quality video and I've this is
what I mean by quality too I mean
content value not production value back
to not editing content value would be
you put your phone on some shoe boxes in
front of a window the uh there's carpet
on the floor and you're it's a smaller
room so just the on camera phone
microphone is good enough like so you
have no accessories no gear great and
but people can hear you they can see you
you got some daylight the production
value is not that impressive it's not a
fancy camera but the content value is
the title you thought about the topic
you know the audience cares about
because of research and then the the
investment you've put in into the
information that you're sharing and so
um think about that content like high
quality content and I've heard it said
that the definition of Excellence is
doing the best you have with what you
have right now so Excellence is a
spectrum of course if you're not
comparing yourself to other people you
just want to beat your previous best if
you start messy if you have a decent
level of clarity of this is the
direction I'm going this is who my
Channel's for what problem is going to
solve and then you commit to once a week
a lot of things can happen momentum
happens you learn learn as you go you
start getting a feedback because you're
putting outputs out there um you're you
evaluate the results as you go and you
are continuing to approve we always say
get 1% better Baseline upload one high
effort based on the resources you have
and the time you have video per week and
commit to that you're going to see crazy
momentum over the next year if you
enjoyed this content and want to take
your YouTube channel to the next level
just click or tap the link on the screen
or go to tube 1K challenge.com to join
our next live YouTube challenge you'll
learn our best tips and strategies that
are working here at think media and I
think you'll love it